haz lo que a mí me ha llamado la
atención de ambos candidatos es la falta
de capacidad para darnos mayores
detalles cómo van cómo van a implementar
estos planes en el caso particular de
keiko por timón yo respeto estas
entregas de beneficios bonos está
hablando un 40 por ciento de la entrega
del icann a un minero es las regalías
generadas por la minería en el caso del
castillo acaso la falta de programa sea
más estás moza no de hecho cuando la
candidata fujimori le pregunto cómo es
que ustedes van a asegurar la vacunación
para todos los peruanos hacia el 31 de
diciembre de este año termina
respondiendo sobre la creación de un
ministerio de ciencia y tecnología
entonces creo que los dos candidatos dan
uno
generalidades y en realidad lo que
propone castillo me estoy refiriendo a
él expresamente no es un sentimiento en
contra de quienes han manejado el estado
en los últimos años y en el caso de
keiko fujimori lo que ella está dando es
acaso con mayor inteligencia estratégica
está dando recetas para ciertos sectores
específicos hablo directamente de los
pescadores hablaba sector turismo hablan
los agricultores y dando ciertos
incentivos beneficios pero no sabemos
eso cómo se articula con la política
general y eso es lamentable porque
estamos en una segunda vuelta en donde
el perú está en una de sus crisis
más agudas desde los años 80 no hemos
estado en una situación como ésta